the uk's medicines regulator has now
approved moderna's covert 19
vaccine for use it is the third such
vaccine
to be approved more than 30 000 people
took part in clinical trials for the
moderna vaccine in the united states
like the pfizer vaccine it requires two
separate doses
studies have shown it to be 94 effective
and it works across all age groups the
uk has now
ordered 17 million doses that's enough
for eight and a half million people the
vaccine is the most expensive available
it comes in at 28 pounds
per dose it also needs to be stored at
minus
20 degrees for skies adele robinson
is in oxfordshire for us uh adele says
only good news isn't it might be
expensive it might be hard
to handle but it can only be good news
to have another vaccine available
yeah that's right it's it's a huge boost
as the health secretary put it today
this is another weapon in in our uh
arsenal against covid19
as you say we will soon have
three vaccines in circulation as part of
the government's vaccination program
the pfizer biontech vaccine the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine and now
the moderna vaccine today as you say the
medicines regulator has authorized its
use after what it describes as
months of rigorous clinical trials
involving
tens of thousands of people so 30 000
people in the u.s took part in these
clinical trials and it was found
to be 94 effective in preventing the
disease
uh including in the elderly and anyone
who uh got the disease
nobody suffered with it on a severe
level
um it's similar as you say to the pfizer
vaccine in that it's
um it's an mrna vaccine which basically
means scientists have been able to
replicate the genetic code of the virus
and as you mentioned there as well the
government made an initial
order of seven million doses of this
vaccine
last year they have since increased that
by another 10 million doses
however we won't be able to see this in
circulation
until the spring because according to
the mhra
moderna needs to expand its production
capability
uh it will be taken out into the
community in
in a similar way to what we've seen so
far so hospital hubs
will be used uh to vaccinate those in
the nhs
and other care staff on the front line
as well as uh
older patients there'll also be specific
specialized vaccination sites across the
country and also
we'll have local community services like
gps as well
it's similar to the others in that it
requires two doses of course um
it's different to the pfizer one in that
it needs or the recommendation is the
second dose must take place within 28
days
it'll be interesting to see uh if that
happens though by the
spring the government should be in a
position uh to
well according to its targets uh deliver
vaccinations or administer vaccinations
to
at least two million people per week and
if that's the case and if
as many people as we hope to be
vaccinated are vaccinated by the spring
then perhaps they'll be able to offer
those second doses earlier or there may
be another decision made that
again uh the net public health
priorities will have to be put forward
to get as many people vaccinated as
possible so
um this is a huge boost as i say
and it is as many people have been
describing these vaccines yet another
vaccine will be key
uh to releasing us from the grip of this
pandemic
okay adele thank you